hi I work in IT for a large enterprise
we're currently thinking of
transitioning some of our IT workloads
over to the cloud but are stuck on
getting a perspective of what we have
and what if again IBM cloud product
insights can help by providing a view
into deployed IBM software products
while providing intelligent
recommendations on new powerful
capabilities in the cloud to optimize
our existing IT environment and cloud
investments all by embracing our hybrid
cloud strategy understanding what
software products we have in our current
IT environment and how much we're using
today is vital
tracking product instances and gaining
deeper insight into usage will allow us
to plan better in the future
next we need visibility into areas of
growth tailored to optimize our existing
investment having access to intelligent
recommendations of cloud services will
help us improve our hybrid cloud
environment simply through a few easy
steps we're able to connect our existing
IT environment to cloud services aimed
at providing customized insights and
recommendations ultimately we've
advanced our digital transformation by
accelerating a hybrid cloud strategy
for more information please visit the
product insights page on the IBM
marketplace
[Music]